comme la première ministre les français
en chante aujourd'hui mais ils ont peur
d'avoir froid cet hiver et ils ont
raison crise énergétique sans précédent
pas de gaz russe une production
nationale historiquement basses
d'électricité des prix élevés c'est
inquiétant pour les ménages et pour
notre économie de production cette
situation était pourtant prévisible en
février nous vous alertons sur le
probable black out et nous avions
formulé 12 recommandations évidemment
pas de réponse mais nous avons surtout
perdu 10 en dix ans de politique
énergétique qui s'est acharné comme nous
l'avons entendu ce matin à détruire le
monde haut d'hier avant de construire
les énergies décarbonées de demain
exemple emblématique que la fermeture de
fessenheim 2 gigawatts dire que nous
rouvrons des centrales à charbon quel
échec pour le nucléaire la ppe prévoit
toujours l'arrêt de 12 autres réacteurs
c'est contraire au discours du président
de la république à belfort qu'en
pensez-vous donc des annonces aux actes
pour cela et pour la construction des
nouveaux apn enfin un court terme pour
garantir la sécurité d'approvisionnement
il nous faut un grand plan d'action
depuis des années le sénat demande la
consolidation la simplification de ma
prive rénove des c2 l'accélération de la
production de biogaz la conversion bio
carburant le retour en grâce de
d'hydroélectricité la simplification des
nerfs avec les collectivités madame la
première ministre
quelle est votre feuille de route
énergétique car nous sommes un peu
perdus devant tant de revirements